hello everybody and welcome to episode
three of buying and selling in Pay
to-play RuneScape uh where we're going
to go from zero to 100 Mil using the
grand exchange only uh so it's going
pretty well we're at 3.9 mil with the
items we have so far and I'll say today
was probably the most progress we've
made uh we made over a mill I think in
one flip uh that comes in near the end
uh so you can just stick around and
watch it or you can just skip to the end
if you want uh yeah so we will just jump
into it here okay so we're just going to
come in here with a couple flips uh we
un fortunately lost the first clip where
we bought them but they're pretty basic
uh just some bow string and Z flips like
we've been doing before um and let's
just do a little calculation here so the
bow strings we actually managed to get a
4 GP margin on and uh we got 10K of
those I can see there yeah 4 GP margin
so we got 40K from the bow strings the
scales we got 3 GP margin on them uh and
we got 8K of those so that's 24K the
Mystic boots were pretty negligible we
only got like 5.5k on those and we're
still selling off these prayer potions
my God they've been in there for so long
okay so I think we're going to do the
bow strings you can see there they still
have a seven GP margin on which is
really good they're a bit high for what
they're normally at but we'll take the
risk just because the reward we can get
back is pretty decent uh so we'll put an
offer in for 179 and we'll buy another
10k of those or
something and once again I think we're
going to do another zra flip um it's
been four hours so I might as well do it
again uh you can get a Max of 30 of
these unfortunately have enough but a
3gp margin is still pretty nice uh we'll
try to get as many as we can not going
to be quite enough to get 30k but we
will go for 10K and hopefully still get
30 GP margin most of the bow strings
have bought uh which is good hopefully
as long as they didn't drop down and uh
we'll get one last item in here with the
rest of our cash and I think with the
last of our cash we'll just go for these
random trimmed armor cuz we don't have
much left um but it would still be nice
to get a bit of money out of it so this
had about a 5k margin on it uh so we'll
go buy 10 of them and hopefully we can
sell them for 50k profit or no more like
75 all right I'll check back in a few
hours okay so we [__] up a little bit
uh the bow strings we lost quite a bit
of money on because they dropped down
which is unfortunate but uh hopefully we
can make it back uh so the bow strings
we actually lost 19 GP on each one
netting us a loss of almost 200k which
sucks
but there's not much you can do about
that the zor skills we got one GP margin
on so we got
10K and the pray potions I honestly have
no [__] idea uh we've been selling
those off for so long I we made money on
it because each stage we slowly dumped
100 more and 100 more we making money on
all of those I'd say we made 50 or 60k
at least so yeah that kind of sucks but
hopefully we can go make the money
back okay so I think we're going to go
with the Mystic boot uh has a 2.5k
margin on a 10K item which is really
good
um so we'll go ahead and buy hopefully
200 of these not super likely but we're
going to leave this in for a while so we
don't want to hit any cap of any kind uh
so we'll put an offering for 200 and
check back in a
while and next up I think we're going to
do the Z scale again because it's been
four hours pretty much so we're going to
go do this again I had about two GP
margin on it which is pretty standard so
we should hopefully get 20 30k on that
and I think for last item we're going to
go with the two do prayer potion uh I
had put a 5 600 GP margin on it which is
pretty good and they do sometimes take a
while to sell but I just couldn't find
anything better for the amount of money
I had left uh so we'll go put an offer
in for like 90 or something or yeah 90
and we'll check back when some stuff's
bought and
sold okay so everything is sold uh
except for the pl legs which are taking
forever um so we sold everything for a
pretty decent profit but unfortunately
we didn't buy as many as we wanted uh
but we'll start with the Mystic boots
here uh we got 2,300 GP profit on each
one which gives us 46k in total which is
pretty decent fortunately we couldn't
get more of those on the twoos prayer
potion we got 730 GP profit on each one
giv us
22k and the Z scales we got a 3 GP
margin on each one giving us a 30k
profit all in all we probably netted
about 100K which is pretty good since
this is a quick flip but uh it would
have been nice had we bought a little
more items but oh well let's just
continue on on here okay so I think
we're still going to go with a prayer
potion because they have been pretty
decent like you can see there it still
has a 800 GP margin on it uh which is
really good for the price point and I
think people will buy them to decant
them so they won't be stuck forever not
selling but uh still it is a risk they
do take a while so I admit that uh so
we'll go buy a couple hundred of these
for 6K even and we won't get that many
but uh hopefully we get
some okay so next up we're going to go
with the Mystic gloves uh they had a 900
GP margin we bought them for 6,900 and
sold them for 6K even uh which is pretty
decent so we'll go ahead and buy a
couple hundred of these and last up here
I think we're just going to go buy some
random piece of uh trimmed armor this
had about a 15K margin on it uh which is
pretty nice we're going to buy it for
about 17K if I can spell adamant
correctly okay there we go the adamant
full Helm we bought for 31k and sold it
for about 17K which is a pretty decent
margin so we'll go buy a couple of these
uh with the remainder of our money and
we'll check back in the
morning okay so we have sold everything
except for the mythal pl legs uh which
was a bad idea uh so the twoos prayer
potion uh we actually managed to get a
820 GP margin on it and we this time we
actually managed to get a good amount of
them we got
176 uh which gave us a 144k profit on
that uh which is pretty decent you can
kind of see there and um the gloves we
got a 940 GP margin on uh we only got 39
of the gloves but that's still 36k from
that and the full Helm we sold for a
11.5k margin which is pretty decent so
uh We've caught back up to where we
started the episode at so let's see if
we can irk up some profit at least uh so
this wasn't an entire waste of
time okay so the two do PA potion still
has a 500 GP margin on it uh actually
even a bit more more like 550 so we'll
still go do this again they were very
successful last time so we're just going
to try them one more time and we'll get
a couple hundred these for about
6260 and hopefully we can buy a decent
amount of these as
well all right so I think we're going to
do the bow string uh has a 4gp margin on
it and I don't know if we're going to
get screwed over again but uh uh we'll
try it again actually Sor it has a 6gp
margin yeah okay we'll go buy some of
these 10K and hopefully this time we
don't lose money on
it okay so I think we're gonna go with
the Navy Cavalier I can see there it has
about a 10K margin on it just a bit less
um it's not traded very frequently but
we'll just put a little bit of our money
in here and buy them for like 6K and
hopefully we can get a little bit money
from these um so yeah we'll just put an
offer in for 30 and we'll check back
when some of these potions have bought
at least there we go uh the bow strings
actually sold for an 11 GP margin which
is quite good um so and we also sold the
myal plate legs off finally those are
gone um so on the bow strings we got an
11 GP margin like I was saying and we
got 10K of them them so that's the 110k
very quick and easy and the the uh the
plate legs we probably got like 2K on on
average uh so we got about 25 to 30k on
those uh kind of got split up over quite
a long period of time so it's hard to
remember um so what we're going to start
off by doing is just dumping these hats
which kind of suck I don't know why I
keep buying these clue Scrolls they're
really not that great uh but hopefully
we will not do that in the future um so
we'll start off by finding a couple more
items okay so I think next up we're
going to try the dragon Arrow uh this is
a heavily traded item and we can just
see what we get the margin at right here
uh so we buy it for
1078 and uh I think we sell it for like
100 GP margin like it's pretty crazy for
how cheap this item is okay so 68 GP
still pretty decent so we'll go ahead
and try these uh so I think we're going
to use the bulk of our money on these
we'll buy them for around 1010 just
about over a k and we'll buy 2K of these
and hopefully these don't screw us over
at all
okay something seriously weird is
happening here you can see the prices of
arrows I just did that we bought them
for 650 and sold them for
261 so we could be losing a lot of money
here or we could be making a lot of
money this is really going to depend on
what I do right now um so we'll explain
a little bit here but first we're just
going to dump the hats here freaking
hats don't need them anymore and we're
going to need as much money out of the
flips we have currently cuz we may need
to invest back into the dragon arrows
when they're super low um so yeah first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to pull these prayer potions even though
they're still selling we need the money
right now uh so I just did a quick
calculation we actually made 480 on each
prayer potion um and we sold 172k of
them sorry 172 of them so far for 82k uh
so we'll pull that money out and yeah so
let's what I just sold a dragon Arrow
what is going on okay so let's slow it
down here so we bought originally the
dragon arrows for10 each for a decent
margin but now they've dropped
tremendously but you can see I've just
boughten 2K arrows for 300 GP which is
insanely lower than what they're
normally at um and then now some of my
arrows are selling so something really
weird is going on here so we've kind of
safe safeguarded our losses by buying
more at such a low price I think in the
business world this called like dollar
cost averaging or something I won't get
into that um but you can see we just we
just got bunch of dragon arrows at 300
GP um so what we're going to do is we'll
put them in here for a little bit higher
than the other ones that apparently are
selling again there must have been an
update release because they're
fluctuating quite a lot uh we're going
to go try to buy and sell one of the
arrow just to see what the margin is at
now but yeah those still seem to be
selling so that's great actually so we
might be primed to make a ton of money
on this item um so yeah let's just check
the margin here to show you how wonk
this is uh say we bomb for 110 which is
my price
and uh we'll have to drop it down to one
GP I think to even sell these it's 1 GP
and 261 look at that that's like a 800
GP margin on a very highly traded
consumable item which is insane uh so
we're going to go put another offer in
here to buy some more of these because
it seems like a great opportunity really
uh so we'll buy him for just a little
less than 400 GP for
397 and we'll try to get 3K of them so
yeah some crazy stuff's happening but I
think in the end we were going to profit
quite a bit off this uh if you just
dumped them right away for the 600 which
what they at you would have lost a lot
so sometimes it's worth seeing if the
item is going to uh kind of level out
and yeah we'll check back in a couple
hours we're not going to leave these too
long okay so we have actually managed to
sell everything here so we lucked out
quite a lot we are done with
everything's out all our money is in and
we made a bunch um so we'll start and
try to simplify this the most um so we
bought three different sets of dragon
arrows at different pric PR points um so
for the first buy where we bought them
at 110 each we sold them back broke even
on exactly the same amount so 2K of
those Arrow we just broke even on now
the rest of them the secondly we bought
another 2K set of dragon arrows but we
got them for 300 each and uh we still
managed to sell them for 990 each which
is a 690 GP margin on it and we that's
on 2K arrows so in total on that second
part of the flip we got 1.38 mil uh
which is the biggest amount in one
single flip that we've ever made um and
for the third set of dragon arrows we
managed to get uh remember we put
another offer in for 397 each I think um
we actually managed to get nearly a k of
those arrows before the pric went back
up to normal um so on those we got a 593
GP margin and sold them sold about 993
of them and so that gave us
558k uh so in total I will just add up
these numbers here 1.3 mil plus
5.58 oh yeah and the uh the hats we
actually manag to sell off as well and
we got 4,200 in each of those uh so
whatever that's another 25k uh so in
total we got 1.8 mil out of that entire
flip pretty much uh even maybe 1.9 mil
which is by far the biggest amount we've
ever got um so that being said I think
this is where we're going to end the
episode as it stands we are at 6.2 mil
now uh so in the episode we made 2.3 mil
which is probably the most we've ever
made on a single episode uh again the
bulk of that is coming from the dragon
arrows but just goes to show that when a
price is dropping going all over the
place actually good opportunity to buy
more of the items instead of just
selling it at lost uh yeah so we did
pretty well this episode and I will see
you guys in episode 4 um if you enjoyed
just hit that subscribe button and I
will see you guys next
time
[Music]